Optimal,
minimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
Don't know how else you
would posting a question.
Now it does seem like I'm a
cybernetic organism living tissue.
Oh,
we'll never interstellar.
This episode is brought to you by convert
kit, my go to email service provider.
A lot of you have asked me what I use
for email and I've been hesitant to tell
you because I don't want to give them
the hug of death and have my own service
drop. So after much consideration
I finally said yes to convert kit.
Being a sponsor email is a huge priority
for me and I trust convert kit as my e
s p my email service provider.
It's the only platform that
I can completely control
and customize and I need a
service that ensures the right information
is sent to my followers and listeners
and I cannot afford downtime.
I have very little patience for it.
So I tried all sorts of
different platforms and
ultimately selected convert kit
because they deliver on what matters most
to me and my team. Easy to use systems,
split testing,
super important and resending technology,
say to unopens high rates of
deliverability and excellent
customer service when
I've needed something from them when
my team has needed something from them,
they've always been there.
So whether you run a business or
just have a professional blog,
let's say convert kit offers email
automation which allows you to send well
timed, targeted content to your
audience or your customers.
The platform has all sorts of integrations
with more than 35 services including
say, hosting sites such as wordpress,
ecommerce platforms like Shopify,
lead capture technology like bounce
exchange or sumo and many, many more.
They offer plans that can adjust to meet
the size of your business and they can
scale with you.
So convert kit can handle you whether
you have a thousand people or 1 million
people on your email list. Let's take a
look, convert kit.com forward slash Tim,
that's Con v,
e r t k,
I t.com forward slash Tim and you
can get your first month for free.
That way you can test the platform,
kick the tires,
make sure that it works for you and
your business and if you're like me,
hopefully fingers crossed because I only
like to recommend things that scale and
do really well for everybody. I hope
that you find they get the job done.
That's certainly been the case for me.
Again,
that is convertkit.com forward slash
Tim for a free month of email services.
Check it out.
This episode is brought
to you by four sigmatic,
founded by the Genius Fin's who lit the
Internet on fire and you may have heard
of their mushroom coffee,
which features Chaga and lion's mane,
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm.
I use it pretty much every day,
either that or the Chaga,
which is decaf.
There's a separate version and I use
both of these primarily for focus and
productivity.
They just get you going let
you up like a Christmas tree,
so definitely check it out.
People are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer. I try to
force this on all of my house guests.
It is a hell of a thing.
If I have employees or people come over
who are working on projects with me,
I always try to feed it to them because
I'm going to get the limitless effect
and get a lot more out of them.
The first time I mentioned this product
and four sigmatic on the podcast,
their product sold out
in less than a week,
so you may want to check them out soon.
If you're listening to this and
the coffee tastes like coffee,
it takes just seconds to
prepare with hot water.
And oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine,
so it has less than half of what
you'd get in a regular cup of coffee.
I don't get any jitters, acid reflux
or any stomach burn, any of that.
It's very unusual and very, very
cool. So if you don't like caffeine,
they also offer very strong,
but caffeine free mushroom elixirs,
which I will sometimes have
in the evening. I find Chaga
specifically to be very,
very grounding and earthy.
So that is another option.
And I have a cupboard full of
their products, uh, at the moment,
which is right around the corner of
my kitchen. You can try something.
You can try sample pack,
which is great also right now by going
to foursigmatic.com forward slash. Tim,
that's foursigmatic, F, O,
u, R, s. I, g, m, a, T, I c.
Dot com,
forward slash Tim and use the Code Tim
Tim to get 20% off of your first order
and they're not that expensive. Anyway,
if you are in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be disappointed,
so try them out.
No ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to interview
people from many diverse fields,
different arenas of
competition or lack thereof,
to dissect what makes them the
best at what they do, the habits,
routines, philosophies,
beliefs, et Cetera, that you
can apply in your own life.
This episode we have
Sharon Salzberg as AOL, z.
B. E. R. G. You can find her on Twitter.
I believe it's just at Sharon Salzberg
and Sharon is a central figure in the
field of meditation,
a world renowned teacher and New
York Times bestselling author.
She has played a crucial role from
the very beginning in some respects in
bringing meditation and mindfulness
practices to the West and very much into
mainstream culture since 1974 when she
first began teaching c is the cofounder
of the insight Meditation
Society in Barre,
Massachusetts and the author of several
books including the New York Times
bestseller, real happiness for
seminal work, loving kindness,
which we'll get into in
real happiness at work,
very well known for her down to Earth
Style and you'll get a firsthand view of
that when you listen to this.
She offers a secular and modern approach
to Buddhist teachings making them more
accessible than I think some of the
esoteric varieties would be two,
type a personalities like you friend
listening to this podcast probably she's a
columnist for on being a contributor to
Huffington post and the host of her own
podcast, the Metta hour,
m, e, t, t a, and a.
We will get into what that means.
Her newest book is real love,
the art of mindful connection.
And I wanted to speak with
Sharon for a long time.
I've read her work,
I've heard her audio and it's very
meaningfully impacted how I operate in the
world,
how I perceived myself and others and
ultimately that has made me both more
effective and given me a
greater sense of wellbeing.
So I hope that you pull some
of that from this conversation.
We bounced all over the place.
I ask some very personal self
interested questions, uh,
which I think make the
answers practical also and a,
there you have it.
So I hope you enjoy as much as I did this
wide ranging conversation with Sharon
Salzberg. Sharon, welcome to the show.
Thank you.
I have been looking forward to this
conversation for some time and I'm glad we
could finally make it happen.
The construction around
your apartment in New York,
not withstanding and uh,
I know that you have to
be out, uh, at a set time.
So I'd like to just jump right into it
and begin at the beginning in a sense
with a question related to your youth
and if you're comfortable sharing the
story. Could you tell us about
your experience that you had?
I think it was at nine years old when you
were dressed in your Halloween costume
and watching Nat King Cole.
Yes. I, uh,
my mother died when I was nine and it
was that night when I was nine that my
mother started hemorrhaging. I was alone
in the house with her and, and she, uh,
I got ended up getting an ambulance and
she went to the hospital and she died
about two weeks later.
And um,
it was much later when I was
writing a book called faith,
which is kind of like my faith journey
that I looked back over my life from the
time it was born till the
time I went to college at 16.
And I realized that I had lived in five
different family configurations along
that time.
And each one of them had been
altered by trauma or death or a,
some kind of really no
terrible circumstance.
And what, what was your relationship like
with your father when you were younger?
Well, my parents had had
divorced when I was four.
And my father, as far as I can recall,
it was really like my hero, you know,
he was, he was the love in my
life. And then he was just gone.
He completely disappeared and there
was no contact whatsoever. Uh,
from the time I lived with my mother
after I was, after they split up, uh,
on her siblings from the time I was
fortunate the time I was nine. And, um,
at that point, after she died, I ended
up living with my father's parents,
whom I hardly knew.
And that was the first time that.